Der hyper look scheint wirklich unaufhaltsam zu sein entgegen allen skeptikern klappt alles wie am schnürchen und nachdem anfang des jahres der startschuss
für die erste europäische teststrecke gefallen ist gibt es jetzt schon die erste
fahrfähige kapsel zu bestaunen wie was wo jetzt in klicks um
science-fiction in den e on mars chroniken hier gibt es täglich science videos abonniert den kanal dort verpasst ihr nichts herzlich willkommen
Vielen mass idee eines hochgeschwindigkeit
transportsystems durch vakuumröhren scheint doch gar nicht so schlecht gewesen zu sein die entwicklung scheint richtig schnell an fahrt aufzunehmen
und das im wahrsten sinne des wortes er selbst ist ja nur am rande damit befasst kommerziell
entwickelt wird der heimklub dagegen von firmen die gar nichts mit max firmenimperium zu tun haben eine davon ist hyper loop transportation
technologies hyper looked at t und die haben jetzt die erste kapsel vorgestellt de kall borneo von heiko lugt idee dazu
war haimanot geht es um mehr als schnelle beschleunigung und das brechen von
geschwindigkeitsrekorden es ist eine echte chance ein effizientes und sicheres system mit einem einzigartigen erlebnis für die reisenden zu erschaffen und
maske hatte die bahnbrechende idee aber gab sie frei jeder darf entwickeln und bauen und die idee super einfach rohrpost
und die könnte der
magnetschwebetechnik jetzt im nachhinein zum erfolg verhelfen
beim transrapid hat es ja nicht so richtig geklappt das prinzip der zug oder beim piper loop eine katze wird in eine röhre
gepackt und in der herrscht ein vakuum bzw ist kaum noch luft enthalten ein sogenanntes teil warum
hochleistungspumpen pumpen die luft auf der röhre und erhalten das vakuum der effekt es gibt keinen
luftwiderstand mehr das hauptproblem und der energiefresser jedes schnellen transportes das ist einfach weg
damit brauche ich für den zug kaum noch energie ist er einmal beschleunigte sollen solarzellen auf den
transporteuren ausreichen um für die energie zusammen mit rund 1200 kilometer pro stunde soll er zwischen metropolen verkehr
schneller als mit einem flug ton und maske hält sich bei der entwicklung eben vollkommen raus und besuch vielleicht mal ein
standorte der
konkurrenten denn auch virgin chef richard branson ist man wieder mit am start er hat das zweite unternehmen das am hyper luft dran ist gekauft
aus heilbronn
wurde virgin blue
band ja mal sehen wer das rennen hier macht auf jeden fall hat hyper lobt die jetzt mit der neuen kapsel die nase vorn
die neue kapsel quintero wann ist rund 32 meter lang wiegt 5 tonnen und enthält eine 15 meter lange
passagierkabine die ist allerdings noch gar nicht eingerichtet
gefertigt ist sie aus wie braun ihm nicht von ungefähr heißt es
dieses material genauso wie das aus dem das schild von captain america gefertigt ist doch es ist ganz normalen irdischen ursprungs
entwickelt wurde es von dem slowakischen unternehmen
2 es zeichnet sich durch eine besondere härte und steifigkeit aus es besteht aus kohlefasern ist also besonders leicht und zehn mal
härter als stahl und zweieinhalb mal so steigt wie aluminium darüber hinaus ist es mit sensoren durchsetzen die die hülle ständig auf temperaturstabilität
und schäden untersuchen zudem ist die hülle der kapsel
mehrschichtig also selbst wenn etwas passiert bleibt sie sicher dabei soll eine neue
magnetschwebetechnik eingesetzt werden bei der deutlich weniger energie verbraucht wird
permanentmagneten die im sogenannten halbach
angeordnet sind sollen zum einen die magnetkraft in die kapsel nahezu auf null reduzieren und im gegenzug
unten zum transport track verstärken indirekt heißt die technik die von hyper lob transportation
technologies angewendet wird und auf der teststrecke mit dieser technologie in toulouse in frankreich soll jetzt die neue kapsel zum ersten mal getestet werden
sie ist erst mal nicht besonders langen diese teststrecke
320 meter die röhren haben einen durchmesser von vier metern und sind damit für güter und auch schon für den personentransport
geeignet aber hier kann schon getestet werden im nächsten jahr soll dann eine längere teststrecke fertig werden wo der quintero wandern auch zum ersten mal
passagieren transportieren wird wo
der hype allouche ein schneller realität zu werden als so mancher vermutet hätte
ich bleibe auf jeden fall dran und wenn er als erstes neues zum hyper lob und zu allen anderen themen erfahren wollt denn endet meine
telefonnummer hierbei whatsapp dann erfahrt ihr von mir vor allen anderen vom neuesten video tägliche und garantiert und zur überprüfung
noch ein kleines geschenk einfach hier draufklicken und natürlich nicht das abo mit der
glocke vergessen und darunter geht es weiter mit
dafür auch draufklicken helfer luke deutsche strecke geplant ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran